[Musique]
et bien oui je suis une femme et j'ose
me présenter comme candidate à la
présidence de cette république d'hommes
c'est légal et pourtant cela choque cela
paraît étrange même aux hommes de gauche
et cela doit l'être puisque je suis la
seule certes les grands partis se disent
tous partisans de l'égalité des hommes
et des femmes et ils n'en finissent pas
de voter et de revoter des lois sur
cette égalité mais quand il s'agit de
donner des responsabilités quand il
s'agit de commander de diriger alors
tous ces hommes-là considèrent que cela
doit rester une affaire
d'homme bien sûr parmi eux personne
n'ose dire que les femmes ne sont pas
capables d'exercer telle ou telle
fonction mais dans les fites quelle
place font-ils aux femmes sur plusieurs
centaines de ministres qui se sont
succédés depuis 30 ans seulement deux
femmes femmes aujourd'hui au Parlement
sur 480 députés et cela parce que tous
les partis en place tous les hommes
politiques qu'ils soit de droite ou de
gauche ne mettent pas leurs actes en
accord avec leurs paroles là comme
ailleurs ils mentent la preuve c'est
qu'aucun grand parti n'a jugé une femme
digne de le représenter à ces élections
à l'usine au bureau dans les services
les femmes n'ont que des emplois
subalternes alors que les hommes sont en
majorité des cadres l'immense majorité
des des femmes qui travaillent sont
commandés par des hommes oh bien sûr on
nous parle à la radio et à l'école de la
dignité d'être mère et de l'importance
du rôle de la mère dans la famille et
dans la société mais toutes les femmes
qui travaillent et qui ont dû demander à
leur chef une autorisation d'absence
pour soigner un enfant malade savent
parfaitement quelle rebuffade et quelle
réflexion elles doivent essuyer voilà la
réalité et il faut la dire les femmes
c'est d la moitié de la population de ce
pays non pas des salaires égaux à ceux
des hommes non' pas des postes égaux non
pas des droits égaux à ceux des hommes
elles sont considérés comme des citoyens
de seconde zone et traités comme tel ce
sont des colonisés des étrangères dans
leur propre pays votre société messieurs
les politiciens n'est pas sortie de la
barbarie et c'est vous qui l' maintenez
y compris vous hommes de gauche car
n'oublions pas que même le le Front
populaire en 1936 n'avait pas donné le
droit de vote aux femmes dans ce pays il
a fallu attendre la fin de la guerre
1945 pour que ce soit octroyé aux femmes
le droit de vote et voilà qui montre
d'ailleurs les limites du bulletin de
vote pour changer notreessort car ce
n'est pas parce que les femmes ont le
droit de vote aujourd'hui que ce ne sont
pas toujours les hommes qui décident
pour elles y compris en ce qui nous
concerne nous directement les femmes
c'est une assemblée d'hommes qui
discuteent depuis des mois voire depuis
des années de savoir si les femmes ont
le droit d'interrompre ou pas une
grossesse non désiré eux parlent de
morale de liberté de droit mais tolère
avec cynisme l'inégalité flagrante
systématique inique dont les femmes sont
victimes alors comme l'ont dit des
centaines de milliers de femmes en
signant une pétition récente je ne suis
pas un homme politique je ne suis suis
pas médecin je ne suis pas juriste je
suis une femme et j'exige le droit de
décider moi-même si je dois ou pas avoir
des enfants et combien et pour que ces
politiciens acceptent aujourd'hui avec
combien de réticence et de dérobad de
discuter de modifier la loi il a fallu
que des femmes courageuses disent
publiquement oui j'ai avorté il a fallu
que des médecins hommes et femmes brave
la loi et l'autorité judiciaire en
proclamant oui j'ai pratiqué des
avortements il a fallu que secret le
mouvement pour la liberté de
l'avortement et de la contraception le
melac et tous ceux qui participent à ce
combat ne sont pas prêts à laisser
l'Assemblée nationale décider seul et à
s'incliner devant ces décisions car les
bourgeois qui se disent partisans de la
libéralisation de la loi sur
l'avortement et ceux qui en sont
adversaires partagent en fait la même
hypocrisie fondamentale car le problème
le problème se posait aussi avec la même
acuité monsieur mitteran quand vous
étiez garde des saau et ministres en
1956 il faut que ces choses-là soient
dites car il n'y a aucune femme dans ce
pays qu'elle soit bourgeoise ou ouvrière
qui n'est été un jour ou l'autre
confronté avec le problème d'une
grossesse non désirée et il n'y a aucune
femme qui n'a senti alors toute la
détresse de sa situation et qui ne se
soit révolté comm contre une législation
rétrograde et hypocrite
elles ont alors réagi selon leur morale
et surtout selon leurs moyens mais
toutes en ont été profondément marqué
pour toutes les femmes de ce pays je
réclame le droit à la contraception
ainsi que le droit car c'est un droit
d'interrompre une grossesse non désirée
en bénéficiant de toutes les garanties
médicales pour les socialistes
révolutionnaire l'égalité de l'homme et
de la femme n'est pas un droit c'est un
fait si la femme occupe aujourd'hui une
situation inférieure à celle de l'homme
ce n'est pas dû à son manque de capacité
qui n'existe que dans la tête des
réactionnaires c'est parce que nous
vivons dans une société d'exploitation
une société qui repose sur l'injustice
et sur l'inégalité et les femmes toutes
les femmes y compris celles de la
bourgeoisie sont victimes de cette
société d'exploitation bien sûr
certaines ont des cages doré mais ce
sont des cages quand même il suffit de
voir avec quelle impudence en cette
période d'élection tous ces ministres
poussent en avant leurs femmes ou leurs
filles comme ils exhibent leur propriété
ou leur titrre et s'il y a des femmes à
qui ça plaît et bien tant pis pour elle
ce n'est pas à elle que je m'adresse
mais à toutes celles qui aspirent à être
reconnu comme des êtres humains à part
entière et si des femmes de la
bourgeoisie ne votent pas pour moi parce
que je suis une militante d'extrême
gauche cela ne me gêne pas mais elles
ont tort car elles ont le choix entre
leur conscience de classe et leur
conscience d'être humain car c'est
précisément parce que j'appartiens à un
mouvement révolutionnaire que je suis là
ce soir et que je peux parler pour
toutes les femmes ce n'est pas la seule
raison pour laquelle je me présente mais
CEN est une importante et je parlerai
des autres dans mes prochaines
interventions mais si je suis la seule
candidate féminine ce n'est pas un
hasard et toutes les femmes qui en sont
conscient doivent le marquer le 5 mai en
votant pour ma
candidature
[Musique]